alors samedi en fin d'après midi c'est
dans le sud de paris une patrouille
aurait vu le rappeur pnl a des mots en
train de préparer une cigarette
artisanale dégageant une forte odeur
caractéristique du cannabis tu le
contrôle d'identité ensuite dégénéré
regardez les images après vous allez
nous dire ce qui s'est réellement passé
bono pas parce que vous avez eu les
policiers vous avez aussi une version
malek délit c'est parti regardez
regardez ce qu'on lui fait alors bruno
pomart vous avez eu vos collègues qui
l'ont interpellé c'est ça tout à fait
l'équipe que vous voyez là j'en ai eu un
parmi eux qui maquille maquis m'appeler
cet après midi pour me pour me parler de
ce qui s'était passé savez c'est
l'utilisation légitime de la force ça
s'appelle un c'est à dire qu'il ya eu ou
vous avez forcément du côté de police
oui oui mais quand il faut et quand il
faut taper le sujet mais mieux le polo
du raid aujourd'hui ouais mais bon ça
c'est faux non c'est une interpellation
classique comme il y en a toute l'année
et tous les jours et dans n'importe
quelle ville de france pas que quartier
jeudi villes de france je pense que sur
le cas de ceux de ce rappeur bon ça
tombe sur lui évidemment qui est connue
donc automatiquement les réseaux sociaux
se sont acharnés sur les policiers mais
c'est une interprétation classique qui
est fait il est menotté et amené au sol
et menotté et embarqué ce qu'on fait
avec n'importe quel personnage qui est
qui en feraient la loi il faut savoir
alors il enfreint la loi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé exactement
il était sur le alors ce qu'on voit là
c'est juste la fais moi je dirais à
faire avant l'interpellation réel il
était sur le trottoir internement en
train de stylos reconnu au départ oui ça
aurait pu nous montrer ses serveurs non
mais non vous savez les gars y
patrouillent sont là pour faire de la
sécurité publique donc ils sont là pour
interpeller pour voir ce qui va et ce
qui ne va pas et là en l'occurrence
évidemment l'utilisation de ce tube sur
la voie publique est interdite ça vous a
prêché alors donc c'est quoi donc il le
alors que kleber tout simplement que les
policiers l'ont rappelé plusieurs fois
qu'il a refusé de répondre et qui sont
allés au contact évidemment pour
l'interpeller tout simplement et c'est
là qu'a démarré évidemment les insultes
mais voilà ils ont interpellé pourquoi
la bad pour utilisation de substances
simplement que sabine henry il avait une
cigarette irait-il rouler ne s'y arrête
un marchand avec sa femme et ses enfants
voilà c'est exactement le scénario je
dirais de départ et ensuite bien six
étaient soumis et n'oublie fois au
départ tendon il en dit quoi départ il
est agressif avec lui ils ont ils ont
interpellé en lui demandant monsieur
police
il s'est pas retourné plusieurs fois ils
ont ils rappelé pour le pour le pour le
cadre et comme on dit et puis on leur en
donne est arrivé l'altercation comme
qu'on voit à la télé où effectivement il
il a commencé à m'insulter donc il ya
outrage rébellion et utilisation de lits
risque quoi là parce que il est bref ils
risquent savez c'est toujours le
problème de la justice en vain d'en voir
taper sur la justice mais ça va être
jugé qu en janvier le rappel à la loi
il a de bons avocats il a beaucoup
d'argent donc il doit rappel à la loi et
puis voilà l'affairé soit classée
mais ce qui est ce qui est dommage parce
que ce soit pas qui est pas une
comparution immédiate / / / lesure ce
personnage mais comme un autre un celi
il a été haut voilà il était en garde à
vue oui je sais c'est directement
oui mais sur ben oui évidemment
évidemment et la violence outrage
rébellion et moi c'est essentiel avec la
police quand ils sont dans le cadre bien
le camion ça s'est bien passé et très
sincèrement c'est ça ils ont certes un
gars adorable
oui mais le chef mais sûrement adore son
travail trouve qu'il est exceptionnel
mais cyril mon jardin en plus il fait
beaucoup pour des associations je
voulais le dire le groupe enel et voilà
donc c'est vrai que ça m'a un peu blessé
moi de voir ça je suis d'accord avec
vous mais encore une fois il commet une
infraction il est comme tout le monde
n'est pas parce qu'il est rappeur connu
certes ai adoré déjeuner à gindou tomber
je suis sûr qu'il était qu'il était très
courtois avec les policiers dans le
camion dans le oui avril s'est calmé je
pense qu'il s'est calmé il a profité
peut-être un petit peu des réseaux
sociaux encore une fois et des
téléphones qui étaient en nombre pour
effectivement montré peut-être qu'on met
ses a même été un peu le style de vie
quand ces garçons là un petit peu de
d'être provocateur aussi en même temps
mais eux ils sont pas maîtres mots 14
justement être est il vraiment dans leur
coin il faut leur taf
là où ils sont ils savent pas trop à la
mode est dans la lumière ils font leurs
trucs et puis mais cyril ce qui est
regrettable encore une fois c'est un
garçon qui est connue reconnue par des
milliers des centaines de milliers de
justement peut-être parce que et
justement c'est pas un mec qui se
montrent beaucoup c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui fait son travail qui reste
vraiment dans son coin qui fait pas
beaucoup parler lui comme son frère
c'est vraiment deux mecs qui sont qu une
très bonne indication de rang dont il
n'aurait pas dû il aurait dû péter les
plombs très sincèrement je pense que
c'était pas utile c'est un bien qu'il
doit montrer l'exemple il peut le
montrer puisqu'il a des adorateurs un
nombre des trucs que c'est dommage qu'il
ait pété un plomb est arrivé là alors
moins dommage malek délégués après on va
pas répondre à la question bien sûr
la police est-elle trop violente malek
des infos comme si je n'avais pas les
policiers qui sont intervenus mais j'ai
essayé de contacter l'entourage proche
en tout cas des mots mais c'est
quelqu'un de très discret qui parle pas
mais on n'a jamais entendu dans les
médias ni à la radio ni à la télé les
deux se sont exprimés qu'une seule fois
dans un magazine américain
donc selon l'entourage proche de genre
de du chanteur moi je n'y étais pas donc
je vais employer le conditionnel
ils me disent donc que cas des mots
étaient en train de marcher avec sa
femme et son fils que la police est
venue à lui alors tu dis qu'il n'a pas
qu'il ait qui n'a pas répondu à
l'interpellation tout de suite c'est pas
c'est parce que j'ai comme information
oui il est en train de rouler une
cigarette avec du cannabis sur aucun
effraction oui il leur d'infraction ça
c'est sûr oui il veut à voir ce qu'ils
vont lui mettre une amende à cause de
cette eau à cause de cette rentrée à
cause de cette infraction par bon il dit
pas non il est pas non sauf qu'à la fin
on lui met deux amendes une amende pour
le cannabis pour les stupéfiants et une
amende pour le non port du masque la
corse tessin et ne portait pas de masque
également et ses séances et en voyant
cessé ces deux amendes que ça a commencé
à s'échauffer lui enfin l'entourage du
chanteur dit qu'il était prêt à se faire
enfin aaa a coopéré avec la police et
que le ton est monté et que lui était
prêt à se laisser faire menotter sauf
que voilà le monde aussi faisant les
caméras autour ça a donné des scènes
qu'on a vus mais à et donc après dans le
camion tout s'est bien passé au
commissariat où ce mais la toile du
chanteur était pas présent n'y était pas
non plus approcher le même s'il n'y
était pas alors il va la voir la démo
insulté les policiers avant de monter
dans des faubourgs garder
[Musique]
tu penses tu être réglés vous allez voir
regardez regardez ce que je lui fais
mais après il avait donné plus terroir
elles mettront alors la version des
policiers d'après les policiers de
rappeur aurait résisté insulté les
fonctionnaires de police en disant vous
avez de la chance d'être 4 venez on va à
l'abri je fais des sports de combat et
je vous prends un par un comme des
hommes
il a à nouveau provoquer un policier en
lui proposant de se retrouver sur un
ring pour un combat de boxe
oui c'est ce que vous aviez comme comme
un faux comme information oui tout à
fait mais encore une fois vous voyez sur
l'interpellation lacombe il ya rien
d'extraordinaire cesser les images d'un
corps qui parle mais rien
d'extraordinaire si c'était juste
laisser menotter
la situation était fini bruno ils sont
quand même 4 mais on n'est pas sur le
store mais bryant n'est pas sur le ring
de boxe à l'eonia pas question de vie ou
de boxe ou quoi ils sont quatre ben oui
c'est comme ça que samuel eto'o mambé
qu'il le réseau normal
sur le plateau de télé on peut le dire
ça mais moi je trouve ça idiot pour
olivier trouve ça dix pendant ces 10
heures également regarder la vidéo il ya
des garçons qui dit vous êtes 4 laurent
saulnier anton et 4 c'est justement pour
pouvoir interpeller sans violence
si vous êtes seul avec une personne en
face vous êtes dans un combat on vous
fait vous sentir le 2 4 ans puis savait
qu'ils étaient filmés vous avez vu
comment ils prennent des gambas
commencer ça tout le problème c'est que
les policiers sont obligés d'agir en
sachant qu'ils ont des téléphones autour
une hausse aussi le nez cassé un ongle
au type
ça va être un mélodrame mais quel
spectacle il est censé montrer l'exemple
devant les jeunes
est ce qu'on parle comme ça aux
policiers est ce qu'on peut dire à nos
jeunes si on leur en terre elle après
quand vous êtes au sol comme ça
le monde pour clermont
est-ce que clairement s'il avait
obtempéré on aurait plaqué au sol le
dirigeant présent les policiers d'accord
on est dans les faits il a refusé je
suis sûr que tu as arrêté dans l'exemple
mais pour les derniers chasseurs de
l'uem leur garçon refuse de se faire
arrêter
heureusement qu'en france la police peut
utiliser des moyens l'airbus
d'immobiliser c'est la loi oui mais les
rennais heureusement 6 atp 9/n des mois
pour servir à l'égard des défauts n'est
pas ça ça veut dire moins on a le droit
de tout faire et qu'un policier n'a plus
aucune autorité
et là c'est un triste spectacle parce
que les jeunes qui admire ce rappeur et
à juste titre je connais pas
parfaitement la cgt n'en dira qu'à une
carrière exemplaire est nécessaire et
sous huy et qui fait beaucoup je vous
dis pour les associations et tous pas
autre chose c'est des gars vraiment sont
extrêmement discret bref on pas vu mais
on répond à une question sur le
continent noir et voilà mes questions
mais je vous décris un petit peu les
personnages voilà la police est elle
trop violente moi je réponds dans le
cadre des mots non d'accord voilà un
individu qui roule un joint en public
devant son gosse apparemment qui refuse
d'obtempérer qui insultent les flics qui
les menacent le scandale ça aurait été
qu'il ne se retrouve pas en garde à vue
voilà moi je trouve que c'est tout à
fait justifié je trouve que les flics
font preuve de beaucoup de patience
c'est sans doute dû à la présence des
téléphones portables mais j'en ai marre
des fausses victimes et des pseudo
martyrs si vous voulez parler des
violences policières invité jérôme
yes un gilet jaune qui a berné a
surnommé circonstances scandaleuse là il
ya un débat dans le cadre là les ogm il
n'y a plus de débat
il s'est mal comporté il a eu ce qu'il
méritait il y en a aussi beaucoup qu'on
peut pas hésité parce qu'ils sont punis
parce qu'ils sont qui sont à l'origine
de la fonction quand vous encaissez ça
aussi quand vous entendez ça vous dit
quoi vous alors moi je sais ce que vous
pensez que la police a été trop violent
mois dans le coeur la rotation mois dans
le cadre des mauges étais pas donc c'est
la question n'est pas sur le passé va
être tout le monde tout le monde révèle
qu'elle tue l'amour avec moi c'est la
police est elle trop violente
aujourd'hui dans la société gagne
violence qui monte et c'est partout
c'est dans la société mais
malheureusement c'est aussi dans la
police et on le voit depuis plusieurs
années via cédric souvient il ya plein
d'autres manquent on peut citer d'accord
à la même chose oui d'accord oui donc
c'est brice jovial ya des éléments de
l'enquète le dernier éléments de
l'enquète qui a été publié cg pouf
prononcé cette fois avant qu'ils perdent
la vie et j'ai tout fait c'est le même
mot qu'a prononcé gérald darmanin le
must de l'intérieur pour s'exclamer face
à l'expression violences policières
quelle dignité et quelle honte pour la
fin de saison et ça c'est la première
des choses tu nous on tue des nombres le
nombre d'interventions qui à part à je
sais pas pour minimiser évidemment à ce
que je t'assure léchouiller attention
mais le nombre d'interventions cas par
an de la police si la police était
violente
waouh c'est à une manifestation non je
veux même pas blâmer utiliser la force
légitime la peau le jeu bien même pas
des colis c'est parce qu'en réalité
jamais ce qu'ils subissent aujourd'hui
ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont en train
de se passer
ce sont sous tension depuis 2015 ils
sont utilisés et est sûre vu que tu
disais encore une fois on les envoie
après l'école de police
sur le terrain les cieux sans leur
proposer des cdd j'ai une gardienne de
la paix aujourd'hui au téléphone qui m'a
dit après l'école de police on m'a
balancé sur le terrain j'ai jamais eu
d'entraînement a pris pour les
interpellations avec excellence lui
fasse la différence entre show via et
demi oui alors du tout la même chose
ce n'est pas un mac 2000 je crois le
jeune vous a pas entendu sur ce sujet et
après on est jeune et qu'on revoie les
infos qu'on a avec bruno pomart sur
cette interpellation de samulski a
beaucoup de gens qui nous disent c'est
pas encore bien claires dans leurs têtes
sur les réseaux d'eau combat on va
revenir là dessus oui j'en ai vraiment
je suis je suis assez fasciné par la
manière dont à chaque fois qu'on voit
des images comme ça sortir sur les
réseaux sociaux
en profite tout toujours c'est
d'ailleurs souvent le fait de l'extrême
gauche ou en tout cas de gens qui
refusent l'autorité de la police en
général parce que c'est un combat
politique fasse mentir pour poser la
question des violences policières
et moi je vais vous dire contrairement à
ce que disait malek tout à l'heure je
pense exactement l'inversé je suis comme
darmanin quand il dit j'ai tout faux
sujet avec des questions sur les
violences policières
je pense en fait que les policiers sont
victimes de violence est en fait pour le
coup on érige le la question des
violences policières en symbole parce
que on voit beaucoup d'image on dit en
fait c'est un système violent parfois
même raciste et donc il faut en tirer
des conclusions magie c'est exactement
l'inversé si vous prenez juste les
chiffres il faut être un peu précis il
ya je parle sous votre contrôle autour
d'une cinquantaine d'agressions de
policiers par jour en france on est au
delà de dix mille depuis très longtemps
car nos parents
donc c'est servir faut imaginer 50 fois
par jour quelqu'un qui décide de s'en
prendre à l'autorité de l'état ces
monstrueux c'est énorme et c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne rappelle jamais on ne
parle jamais des violences faites aux
policiers
ensuite la deuxième chose c'est que
c'est le refus de l'autorité là dans le
cas précis de l'interprète de
l'interpellation de ce rappeur à
l'origine il ya un refus de se soumettre
aux contrôles
c'est quand même ça le point de départ
du problème si il avait décidé il avait
accepté de se soumettre et pas soyons là
et on n'a pas dit qu'il avait refusé de
se soumettre aux contrôles mois écouter
s'il part on y roule un joint il discute
avec les flics en disant qu'il veut pas
obtempéré et à la limite même en règle
générale je sais pas il ya quelques
semaines j'ai été fait j'ai été
complètement retourné par les images de
gamin après la défaite du psg qui
courent après les bagnoles de flics en
leur tapant dessus et c'est dans quel
pays on vit pour que des gens n'ai plus
peur à ce point-là de l'autorité de la
police
donc ça crée un système où à la fin ils
sont agressés en permanence et si vous
prenez l'histoire de la police mais ton
seulement depuis dix ans vous avez
premièrement les réductions d'effectifs
merci la droite vous avez ensuite une
compassion systématique pour les gens
qui se font taper par les flics merci la
gauche
ensuite vous avez la suspicion avéré
c'est ça qu'on a inventé comme terme ya
pas longtemps
merci castaner vous avez ces trois
choses là qui font qu'en fait ce sont
devenus des cibles dans la société
donc ils sont en permanence attaqué ils
ont aucun autre moyen de se défendre à
part par la voix de certains pour
représentants sur les plateaux
télévision moi je trouve que c'est
monstrueux et que notre rôle c'est de
rappeler que c'est eux qui ont en effet
la ligie la légitimité de la de la
violence donc à un moment donné il faut
s'y soumettre sinon l'état de droit ne
fonctionne plus alors